madison mills if you haven't already
downloaded the insanely popular app tick
tock you're running out of time to do so
because as of sunday tick tock and
wechat will be banned from
us app stores joining us to talk about
this and more is bloomberg news is kurt
wagner kurt thank you so much for
joining us yet again this week to talk
about tick tock
yeah it's the story that uh that won't
go away so i'm happy to be here
just keeps on giving uh so first can you
just break down
the the latest how does this impact what
we're gonna see on
on app stores on sunday yeah so last we
spoke a few days ago
uh we were getting close to what seemed
like a finalized deal
between uh bike dance which owns tick
tock and oracle
a u.s company here that was going to
kind of be their partner
in the u.s to handle data and security
issues but what happened this morning
was that the president said no in fact
he's going to move forward on sunday as
you mentioned
and demand that uh tick tock and wechat
which are both uh owned by chinese
companies um
be removed from the apple and google app
stores that means users aren't going to
be able to go in and download them
anymore
uh if you already have the app it will
continue to work but you won't be able
to
get updates so this is a pretty big deal
especially
considering um you know as of yesterday
even it seemed
like tick tock and the treasury
department had come to a bit of an
agreement on what a possible deal would
look like
and how does this impact that deal does
this put any pressure on that timeline
or or what does this mean for a
potential oracle deal
i think it definitely adds uh pressure i
don't think um
that anything's going to necessarily get
done in the next 48
hours because there is actually a
stipulation here the president said
in tick tock's case if they can come to
some kind of a
agreement or some kind of deal that he
believes handles all of the privacy
issues he's worried about
as long as they can get to that by
november the 12th he's willing to
reverse
this ban so while these uh while
tick-tock won't be available in the app
store
there is still a little bit of runway
here for the company to figure out some
kind of arrangement
um that would ultimately reverse this
do you see that ban happening as we get
closer to november 12th then
you know tick tock users like myself are
getting more and more nervous do you
think that that's
that's a thing that we actually need to
worry about
i i don't well i've been wrong
quite often about this whole process
because i think you asked me about a
month ago and i think i said hey
microsoft is in the lead this is
probably going to get sold to microsoft
who's no longer even in the picture
so um my guess knowing
what we know now about the the deal is
that they will get something done by
november 12th it
feels like all sides want something to
get done it just doesn't feel like maybe
they've
been able to strike the right balance
just yet um as of yesterday i was
talking to people who were
uh thinking that you know a a an oracle
announcement could have been made
yesterday it could have been made this
morning so there clearly are people who
feel that they're very close
which makes me believe that they'll
figure something out by november the
12th but
again i have not been very good at
predicting what's going to happen here
this is a very unique
uh situation that i don't think many
people have ever seen before
um so i ask you not to hold me to that
but if i had to guess
i would say that there will be a deal
done before this is a kind of more
permanent ban
fair enough kurt i'm wondering if you
can talk a bit about last time we spoke
you talked about
uh larry ellison's relationship with the
president um
how does this news that we're hearing
today play into that relationship if at
all
well i think that that relationship has
everything to do with um
kind of comfort around fixing these
security
concerns that the president has clearly
they have not
figured that out just yet but you know
this is uh
not something that just two people get
to decide there are a lot of different
uh groups involved here um i mentioned
the treasury department
uh this ban was actually issued by the
commerce department so
even though there is a relationship of
sorts between larry ellison and the
president
um which i think will will help
ultimately probably get a deal done at
some point
it's clear here that there's not just
two people involved right there are a
lot of people a lot of stakeholders
um including people who are probably
much smarter about security
um than than both of those guys only
because they're more in the weeds on it
so um i i don't think that this makes a
huge
issue at the moment but obviously as we
get closer and closer
to something that looks like a real
permanent ban um that could change
and it's important to note that we're
not just talking about tick tock here
right we're also talking about
wechat uh how will this impact wechat
users specifically
wechat is in a bit of a different but
similar boat
uh we chat for those who are unfamiliar
incredibly popular messaging app
in china it's a lot less popular here in
the us but there are still i believe i
saw close to
20 million people in the us who use
wechat
it is also being banned from the app
stores on sunday that means you won't be
able to download it from google or apple
um if you already have the app you can
continue to use it but one thing that's
different about this is that one the
commerce department says
you're not going to be able to make
financial transactions within the app
which is a big part of how a lot of
people use it they use it to make
purchases
and do commerce um the other difference
is unlike tick tock
uh with wechat the government has not
said here's a resolution to
get getting rid of this ban right so
where in tick tock as long as they get a
deal done
by uh that early november date we were
talking about the ban could be lifted
with wechat we don't really have
something like that so at a certain
point
when you won't be able to get app
updates or you won't be able to continue
to
um you know get notifications from the
company to upgrade the software
the app will just become i guess
obsolete at a certain point
not starting sunday necessarily but at
some point in the future
and are there predictions floating
around for how people might handle that
is it something where a competitor like
instagram will really bump up ig reels
or will users just use a vpn
has anyone predicted what the kind of
user behavior around this change might
be
well like i mentioned it's it's not a
huge app uh
at least wechat is not a huge app here
in the us and so
i think a lot of people do use it to
communicate with friends or family back
in china
but really when you're talking about u.s
communication it's going to be imessage
or it's going to be facebook messenger
or instagram or something like that so i
think there's already a lot of
alternatives in place
for u.s communication when you're
talking about tick tock
let's pretend that uh there is a ban at
some point in the future
i think uh instagram is probably the the
most well positioned to take advantage
because you just mentioned
they do have reels they have a a similar
product a lot of the creators that are
on tick tock are already on instagram
so they're kind of familiar they have
built up audiences i think youtube is
another one of course right
where a lot of people who are on tick
tock now already have audiences on
youtube so
i think those two probably stand to
benefit some
but again i i think from a from a more
immediate standpoint because both of
these apps will continue to operate in
the very short term
um it's not really something that i
think has been has certainly been
decided
and kurt a lot of folks are just
starting to join in us uh here on this
live stream so i'm wondering if you can
just
re-walk me through today's news sure and
how it impacts users on tick tock
yeah so the news from today is that um
the president has ordered
that tick tock and wechat which are both
owned
by chinese companies to be banned from
american app stores starting sunday so
that means
uh if you are in the us you won't be
able to download tiktok
from the app store you won't be able to
download it from the google play store
and and crucially you won't be able to
get updates uh for an
app even if you already have it on your
phone so you will be able to continue
using it
as far as we know but you won't
necessarily be able to update the
software which at a certain point
obviously becomes a problem uh down the
line so that's kind of the news from
today is that
starting sunday these apps are no longer
going to be available in
u.s app stores and just again do you see
a world in which we hit that november
12th deadline and suddenly the u.s
just goes dark on tick-tock you're
eventually one of these predictions is
going to be right i'm sure uh
no i i i think that both sides both
sides being
the us government tick tock i think they
want some kind of agreement i think tick
tock obviously very much wants to
operate in the u.s
i think the president realizes that a
u.s version of tick tock is probably
a good thing both for consumers but also
could be good for business could be good
for jobs right if you have another big
tech company
operating out of the u.s but clearly
they're not
able to see eye to eye right now on what
a deal like that looks like
the good news is as you mentioned
november 12th that's almost two months
away so there is a bit of runway here
for them to figure that out before there
is a more permanent ban
um and i believe that they'll probably
get something done but i would have told
you they would have got something done
by now
so uh you know what do i know what do i
know madison we're figuring it out as we
go
um we only have a couple more minutes
with you real quickly i just want to ask
do you think november
12th it's right after another important
november date of november 3rd for the
election do you think there's any
correlation there or decision making on
that date that relates to the election
maybe perhaps but it's it's hard to
imagine you know if uh
president trump does not get reelected
for example obviously
uh joe biden wouldn't it wouldn't be
inaugurated until in january
it's not as if suddenly you know he's
going to be able to swoop in and save
the day
perhaps it could be something where uh
you know depending on the outcome of the
election maybe the
the president sees this as a a kind of
uh uh
a flag that he can plant one way or the
other either for you know the beginning
of his next term or or
on his way out but you know at this
point i think
there's it could get done before then i
think there's a realistic possibility
that it will get done before then
um so i'm not really looking too much at
the election date but as you point out
all of this to be happening right around
the same time it's certainly uh
something to pay attention to and keep
watching
kurt thank you so much for making time
to join us today and for those watching
thanks for
taking time to chat with us uh please
follow bloomberg quick take wherever you
get your news on all social platforms
and have a great friday thank you so
much